[Musique]
est-ce que vous m'avez
donné j'ai mal que souffre et là il va
m'en manquer pour demain me donne de en
dépanage pour ce soir mais pour demain
j'enai pas et c'était quoi comme
médicament amoxyiline
OK donne le
code il faut que je prend des m matins
forcment et oui c'est problématique par
je va travailler jusqu'à 3h du matin
donc essayer de voir avec le médecin sil
donne autre
chose pour éviter que vousyez
partout cette année ça touche vraiment
les traitements de base un antibiotique
de premier recours pareil les
anti-inflammatoires comme la cortisone
ça c'est quand on est en épidémie c'est
vraiment les molécules qui qui sort tous
les jours et on appelle n grossisse tous
les jours et là en ce moment je reçois
rien c'esttill d'accord là je vous
montre que des
Entilles et là quand j'ouvre le tiroir
quand je regarde j'ai plus qu'une boîte
d'amoxycyline
et on passe notre temps à à essayer de
trouver une solution pour le patient on
passe notre temps à appeler les médecins
que les médecins essayent d'adapter leur
leur traitement en fonction de ce qu'on
a en stock on a la possibilité euh pour
certains médicaments comme des
antibiotiques de donner les médicaments
on comprimer prèts c'est chronophage
parce qu'il faut faire le travail il
faut vérifier les dates de perempption
la traçabilité il faut expliquer aux
patients et cetera c'est quelque chose
qui va nous permettre d'économiser
quelques boîtes sur une centaine de
boîtes c'est vraiment c'est c'est pas
c'est pas la panassée alors s'il vous
plaît j'ai besoin d'une préparation
d'amoxiciline sin hop merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
on a notre activité classique qui était
là déjà présente et nous c'est du
surplus tout ça à chaque fois ça a été
la mxydine l'année dernière et les
corticoïdes sont arrivés euh et là le
dernier récent c'est la fécaïne quoi et
là ben la demande est très importante
ou il me reste une
boîte alors ça c'est une spécialité qui
en rupture
d'accord
[Musique]
on n jamais jamais vécu une situation
pareille au niveau de la pharmacie
française depuis plus d'un an les
ruptures ne font que s'accentuer on ne
voit aucune solution aucune amélioration
et en ce moment c'est quasiment trois ou
quatre ordonance sur 5 où il manque un
produit ou un médicament une bonne fin
de semaine on vous a conditionné
exactement le bon nombre de géules vous
prenez bien deux géules matin midi et
soir pendant 8
[Musique]
jours c'est toujours intéressant que le
gouvernement s'intéresse au sujet le
problème c'est qu'on a très peu de
réponses qui sont cohérentes après des
mesures toutes simples que le
gouvernement n'a jamais énoncé les
médecins sont au courant de ces rupture
depuis maintenant 1 an pourquoi ne pas
nous prescrire un tiers C
d'antibiotiques ou de corticoïdes dans
l'ordre de leur préférence et les
pharmaciens feront ce qu'ils
[Musique]
peuvent